pour ta jean yves perrin les fêtes
encore avec qu'à strasbourg le marché de
noël c'est en alsace il faut le savoir
que sont nées les traditions du père
noël et du sapin chaque année au mois de
décembre donc un marché de noël
s'installe en ville autour de la célèbre
cathédrale jérôme soûlard sylvain
gauthier c'est un drôle de village d'une
autre époque qui n'a pourtant jamais
vieilli le crij kindle ce mairie coup le
marché de noël quand mille et une
lumières veux l'honorer l'enfant jésus
village des sourires des couleurs
irréelles cinq siècles de traditions
religieuses et païenne qui font
aujourd'hui de strasbourg la capitale de
noël je connais plusieurs marchés
européens mais je pense que c'est le
plus beau
le plus animé c'est maya un cachet
spécial spécial car ici la chaleur de
noël c'est d'abord c'est mélanger ces
odeurs les alsaciennes c'est comme ça
c'est une tradition chez noël
nous verrons pas un noël sans venir au
marché de noël voyez ça c'est ne se fait
pas voilà voilà
et tu mangeais un petit peu commun quant
aux enfants les véritables petits
princes de noël ici ils deviennent sage
et même raisonnable tu crois pas que les
trop grosses pour toi ça va
et quand les ventres sont bien remplies
ce sont les yeux éblouis de surprises
qui s'appuie yonne de bonal
c'est vrai que ça va être quand même
chanson 26 ans décrit ce cadre il existe
alors là c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
sensationnel des couleurs il dit cadeaux
par milliers qui sont à vous maintenant
pour quelques secondes seulement à
l'aller c'est ce qu'on peut pas tout
acheter
strasbourg et sa magie de noël
un drôle de village décidément venue
d'une autre époque qui l'a pourtant
jamais vieillir
m